sabemos que la rusia de vladimir putin
es una fuente inagotable de controversia
y que en youtube es siempre uno de los
temas más calientes de hecho cada vez
que hemos tocado el tema visual político
siempre hemos recibido una avalancha de
comentarios y mensajes muy polarizados
muchos nos han acusado de ser anti putin
y otros de justo todo lo contrario lo
cierto es que ni lo uno ni lo otro hemos
hablado ya en diferentes vídeos de
muchos aspectos de este gigantesco país
pues bien en este vídeo queremos
realizar una radiografía sobre las
políticas económicas de putin porque
amigos rusia se encuentra en una
auténtica encrucijada
aunque nos pueda sorprender cuando el 1
de enero del año 2000 putin asumió la
presidencia de rusia no parecía existir
hostilidad alguna hacia eeuu la unión
europea o el resto de lo que podemos
denominar como el bando occidental de
hecho en su primera entrevista para la
bbc
putin afirmó lo siguiente no me puedo
imaginar mi propio país en forma aislada
de europa por lo que es difícil para mí
visualizar la otan como un enemigo a
tenor de los acontecimientos vividos
parece difícil de creer sin embargo esta
fue una posición que sobrevivió bastante
tiempo y no solo ocurría esto en lo
referente a la política internacional el
aperturismo del primer gobierno de putin
se observa también en su política
económica por ejemplo a los pocos meses
de ser presidente putin nombró como
ministro de economía y comercio a un
economista liberal a german gref el cual
elaboró un programa económico que se
estructuraba atentos bajo dos heridas
principales uno la primacía del
individuo sobre el estado y dos la
necesidad de aprovechar los altos
precios del petróleo para realizar
mercado en la misma línea putin también
contrató como su consejero económico
principal a andrey diario nov un
economista también liberal que forma
parte del cato institute para los que no
lo conozcáis un fin tan liberal con sede
en washington expanden
ya os podéis hacer una idea economistas
y reformas por mercado aperturismo en
los primeros años todo apuntaba a que
rusia estaba transitando de forma
definitiva hacia el club de las
potencias occidentales bueno es que
incluso hubo que impuso sobre la mesa
una posible adhesión de rusia a la unión
europea como en cambiar los tiempos
la época dorada de puig en el resultado
de todo ello fue más que exitoso durante
los primeros ocho años de gobierno de
putin la economía rusa creció una media
del 7% anual la estabilidad y las
reformas impulsaron con fuerza la
inversión y los capitales
internacionales prácticamente llovía
sobre el país sin embargo junto esa
tendencia también se empezaron a
percibir ciertas sombras
putin desencadenó al poco de acceder al
gobierno una guerra contra la oligarquía
que controlaba muchas de las varias
corporaciones rusas vamos a ver no es
que esos oligarcas fueran precisamente
empresarios limpios la mayor parte de
ellos utilizaron métodos más
cuestionables como el soborno para
hacerse a precio de ganga con muchos de
los activos de la antigua unión
soviética
mi opinión algunos de ellos llegaron a
mi oficina cuando yeltsin dijo que iba a
presentar mi candidatura y me dijeron sí
sabe usted que aquí nunca va a ser
presidente y ya veremos pero es que las
prácticas de putin para conseguir su
lealtad o quitarse del medio a quienes
no se subordina cena él tampoco fueron
precisamente ortodoxas el mejor ejemplo
es el caso de mijail
el propietario de yukos la mayor
petrolera del país y que era considerado
por aquel entonces como la persona más
rica de rusia pues bien jodorkovski cree
y no es intocable comenzó a financiar a
partidos políticos de la oposición el
resultados en octubre de 2003 en
vísperas de las elecciones
parlamentarias fue detenido por una
unidad especial de los servicios
secretos condenado a nueve años de
cárcel y además el estado ruso le
expropió su empresa y la mayor parte de
su fortuna amnistía internacional lo ha
considerado siempre como una condena
política el tribunal permanente de
arbitraje de la haya ha condenado a
rusia a indemnizar con 40.000 millones
de euros a empresas del que fuera el
hombre más rico de rusia mijaíl
jordorkovski en 2005 andrei área nov el
economista ha contratado como consejero
económico principal dimitió e hizo la
siguiente afirmación rusia se está
convirtiendo en un país diferente rusia
ya no es un país democrático ya no es un
país libre así transcurrieron las cosas
hasta que en 2008 la crisis
internacional le asestó un duro golpe a
la economía rusa que en pocos meses
un 10% a partir de ese momento todo
cambió el estado cogí el testigo y los
años siguientes utilizo los ingentes
recursos procedentes del boom petrolero
y las materias primas para incrementar
el gasto público modernizar el ejército
y consolidar un modelo de estado muy
paternalista entre 2009 y 2014 el peso
del estado en la economía se duplicó
pasando del 35 al 70 por ciento además
putin acabó en la partida con el
federalismo y las libertades civiles
comenzaron a sufrir la crisis
en 2012 antes siquiera que los precios
de empezarlo comenzaron a caer la
economía rusa ya dio muestras de
debilidad y comenzó a desacelerarse la
elevada dependencia del petróleo la
falta de competencia su pobre
integración en el comercio internacional
o la falta de seguridad jurídica fueron
algunas de las causas de su
estancamiento y claro cuando en 2014 los
precios del petróleo y las materias
primas se vinieron abajo la economía
rusa siguió el mismo camino en las dos
primeras semanas de enero el precio del
crudo bajó hasta un 20 por ciento
llegando a mínimos históricos- un
castigo que además se vio reforzado con
las sanciones impuestas por occidente
tras la crisis de ucrania y la versión
rusa de crimea consenso para renovar las
sanciones a rusia a los embajadores
europeos se han puesto de acuerdo para
prolongar seis meses más hasta el 31 de
enero del año que viene las sanciones
económicas a rusia el resultado es que
la economía rusa lleva en recepción más
de 20 meses y el número de personas bajo
el umbral de la pobreza
yo solo 2015 en más de 3 millones de
personas hasta alcanzar los 19 millones
además dentro de las medidas de
estabilización se permitía flotar
libremente al rublo lo que le llevó a
perder casi la mitad de su valor
millones de rusos perdieron sus ahorros
casi de la noche a la mañana el consumo
que había sido el principal motor en la
última década
ahora se desploma el dinero se va del
país a causa de las sanciones y la caída
del precio del crudo ya podéis imaginar
el impacto todo esto tuvo sobre la
capacidad de consumo y el bienestar de
la sociedad rosa que soy un patriota de
mi país y no estamos luchando sólo por
nosotros sino porque estamos viendo que
el futuro solo va a peor wind to get
words y es que a pesar de la imagen que
muchas veces proyectan los medios de
comunicación
rusia es hoy uno de los países más
corruptos del mundo y el nivel de vida
de sus ciudadanos es por lo general bajo
esto no es que tengamos manía a rusia
simplemente son los datos
reformas y recuperaciones
a pesar de todo ello en los últimos
meses hemos visto señales positivas el
kremlin ha decido reducir un 30% su
gasto militar y en el índice doing
bussiness que miden la facilidad para
hacer negocios en un país rusia ha
pasado del puesto 120 al 40 haciendo que
sea más fácil hacer negocios en rusia
que en italia de la misma forma en 2015
comenzó a operar la unión económica
euroasiática un acuerdo de integración
económica y libre comercio con la
armenia bielorrusia kazajistán y
kirguizistán y este mismo año también un
tratado de libre comercio con vietnam
parece que la política económica de
rusia está cambiando de rumbo fíjense
esto una zona de libre comercio entre la
unión euroasiática y el sudeste asiático
puede aparecer en un futuro cercano lo
hacemos número uno del kremlin vladímir
putin en esta línea el gobierno ruso se
ha embarcado en un programa de atracción
de inversiones con el que persigue que
las multinacionales trabajen en el país
de hecho en marzo de 2016 las
autoridades rusas invitaron entre otros
al presidente de inditex amancio ortega
a que traslade a rusia
a parte de la producción del emporio
encabezado forzada por su parte la
victoria de trump apunta a mejores
relaciones y tal vez al final es ángeles
recto entendemos que no será un camino
fácil pero estamos listos para hacer
nuestra parte y haremos todo lo posible
para devolver las relaciones
ruso-estadounidenses a un camino estable
y sostenible de desarrollo
y retos y dificultades
ahora bien logran cambiar de rumbo no va
a ser una tarea fácil y es que este país
padece problemas estructurales severos
primero el peso del estado es enorme y
hasta ahora la mayor parte de los planes
para privatizar las empresas estatales
han fracasado
está por ver que putin sea capaz y
quiera desmontar todas las instituciones
sobre las que ha sentado su poder
político y es que la experiencia nos
dice que los proyectos políticos de
desarrollo están condenados al fracaso
si no van de la mano de la iniciativa
privada y se alienta el emprendimiento
es lo que ha ocurrido por ejemplo con
dinópolis con una nueva ciudad levantada
de la nada para albergar empresas
tecnológicas donde hay de todo sarlo
empresas segundo en rusia todo depende
de putin y eso genera poca o ninguna
seguridad jurídica estaría dispuesto a
invertir tu dinero en un lugar donde te
lo pueden quitar mañana si el político
de turno quiere
no
yo el líder ruso incluso acaba de poner
en marcha la guardia nacional un cuerpo
de unos 25.000 hombres directamente bajo
sus órdenes algo así como una guardia
pretoriana para consolidar su poder y la
verdad es que esto un seco pieza no
genera por otro lado la demografía tan
envejecida que presenta rusia la
corrupción generalizada o el importante
peso de los oligarcas y grupos mafiosos
tampoco ayudan en cualquier caso en
visual política esperamos que este
aparente cambio de rumbo se confirme y
entremos en una nueva era de
entendimiento y también prosperidad para
el pueblo ruso porque de momento los
resultados económicos de la de putin son
bastante malos vosotros qué pensáis que
decía eeuu debe tender la mano a rusia
podéis pasaros por nuestro twitter y
dejarnos vuestro voto en la encuesta que
hemos abierto si nos estás viendo y aún
no te has suscrito no te preocupes tiene
remedios puedes hacer clic ahora mismo
en este botón y empezará a formar parte
de esta pequeña gran familia un saludo y
hasta la próxima
ah
por qué